hey you guys we're talking about another
movie today
this movie right here i believe it first
came to vod back in fall of 2021 if i'm
not mistaken
i had actually noticed it first of all
probably like a month or two ago when i
was scrolling through the horror movies
on hulu and i kind of had in the back of
my mind because i was like oh that kind
of looks interesting i really liked like
the graphic of the poster for it i
didn't really know all that much about
what it was about or anything but i kind
of had it in the back of my mind for
later and then one of you guys in one of
our uh live streams like in the chat
recommended it to me i can't remember uh
who it was
but you recommended it and i was like oh
yeah that's on hulu i should probably
watch that pretty soon so i went ahead
and put it on the docket so this is a
2021 film called we need to do something
now i will say from the outset
this movie and i say this a lot but in
this case i think it's
particularly uh apropos
this movie is absolutely way better if
you know like nothing about it go into
because
this movie actually
if you've seen the movie
there's one point in the movie
where
i literally like gasped out loud you
know what i mean and like i got
goosebumps and stuff i was like what you
know what i mean so that was like really
like this big shocking moment
and
so i don't really want to spoil too much
about where this is going
um but i will have to kind of like
describe some of the plot obviously
but if you want to watch this movie i
just think it's better not knowing
anything about it and honestly i guess
like the the the guy that made it like
thought that too because even on hulu
there is literally a bare bones like one
sentence uh you know synopsis of what
the movie is about and that's it it
doesn't really give you much of a clue
about where it's gonna go and i think
that that is the way that you should
approach this movie
uh another thing i will add um i
loved this i thought it was fantastic i
thought it was uh pretty uh ingenious
really
and but i will say that it's not going
to be for everyone
now without spoiling too much two of the
things that i think are going to be a
point of contention actually are a point
of contention because i've seen some
other reviews of this
one no going in that other than a few
flashback type sequences this entire
film
takes place in one location and that
location is a bathroom
uh it's a pretty big bathroom but it's a
bathroom nonetheless so it's basically
four characters trapped in a bathroom
for almost the entire movie other than a
few flashback sequences
secondly
uh the movie if you are the kind of
person that has to have everything
completely explained or you want
everything if you if you don't like
ambiguous endings or
movies that don't show you the monster
or the antagonist or something like this
then you probably will not like this
because this movie
like i said while quite gory and quite
surprising in the directions that it
goes
it leaves some things to your
imagination i actually thought that that
was one of its great strengths and i
don't even know i kind of feel like yes
it could have been done for budgetary
constraints because this is a very low
budget movie
but on the other hand i think it really
worked in its favor as i said because it
leaves a lot of things to your
imagination which i tend to like usually
um because you know what you can imagine
is like scarier than what you can
actually see so i think i think that
worked out a lot better
this story too i kind of feel like if
you go into it thinking that it's
literal i mean
yes it's literal in the sense that it's
a bunch of people trapped in a bathroom
um and it's kind of like structured like
a survival horror
but
there's some other [ __ ] going on in
there that makes me think that maybe
this is meant to be taken not
necessarily completely literally
but
sort of metaphorically or symbolically
you don't have to take it that way it's
still good even if you don't uh buy into
that narrative
but i think it's a much richer
experience if you
look at it in the sense of a metaphor
type of thing and i know that some
people kind of like roll their eyes at
that they just want like a straight
after horror movie this is a straight
ahead horror movie don't you know it's
not anything like that
but it definitely has a lot of subtext
to it if you want to
look into that there is a lot of
symbolism and stuff like that which i
think really elevates the story
so this was made by a guy named sean
king o'grady now i think he'd done some
documentaries and stuff prior to this
and maybe some short films but this is
his first uh feature film
now everybody in this uh is kind of
like all four of the main characters are
pretty much like a horror stalwart
they've been in like lots and lots of
horror movies except for the kid but
even he has uh some horror [ __ ] on his
resume so the mom whose name is diane is
played by vanessa shaw um i recognized
her from come out and play
which i think was a remake of that
spanish uh film that spanish giallo film
she was in 310 to yuma she was in the
hills have eyes remake she was in eyes
wide shut she played domino
and i didn't realize this until today
when i was looking at her imdb
she got her start as the little girl in
hocus pocus which or no she was the
older no that's right she was the older
daughter that like the guy had a crush
on that's right yeah so she was in hocus
pocus that might have been her first
movie for a second i thought it was a
little girl and it blew my mind i was
like no no she was like the older girl
but yeah she was in hocus pocus uh so
yeah so she plays the mom
also uh pat healy plays the dad robert
pat healy has been in
a million movies
uh a lot of horror but a lot of other
stuff too um i recognized him from
several horror movies the innkeepers the
thai west movie he was in that uh he was
in that great movie compliance which was
based on that uh
[ __ ] up true story about that weird
thing that happened at mcdonald's i
think we did a show about it he was in
cheap thrills which is also great if you
haven't seen that uh starry eyes which
is amazing i think it was from 2014
tales of halloween he's been like a ton
of other [ __ ]
uh the teenage daughter melissa is
played by sierra mccormick who is quite
young but it seems like she's kind of
becoming like a
kind of the go-to uh girl for like
horror sci-fi thrillers stuff like that
she was in vfw she was great in that uh
she was in the vast of night so
it seems like she's really going places
and she's really amazing in this
and uh the little boy
uh the little son is uh played by john
james cronin who uh was actually on the
nosferatu tv series so all four of these
will like i said have a lot of horror
stuff on their resume uh this story was
actually based on a 2020 novella
written by max booth iii
so what you have at the very beginning
there's this family uh obviously the mom
the dad the teenage daughter and the
little son
and there's a really really bad storm
coming
so all of them are going to kind of
close themselves off into this big
bathroom that they have which only has
like one
uh entrance from the house and it
doesn't have any windows it just has
some kind of strips of glass blocks and
stuff like that and it's kind of
reinforced so they feel like they're
going to go in here and like sit out the
storm you know just in case
so they all kind of go in there
now from the moment that the family
arrives in here you get a sense
of
what the dynamic of this family is which
is very very very dysfunctional and you
find out later like
why the dad is like acting the ways
because
pretty much as soon as they get in there
the dad
is
really really aggro like maybe like more
than
he should be later on you kind of find
out like what the reason for that is one
he's an alcoholic which they kind of
establish like as uh the story goes on
but
it also turns out that like right before
the storm was gonna hit and right before
they had to close themselves off in this
bathroom he found out some information
about his wife
uh so he's still kind of processing that
and he's not uh taking it all too well
so they're all in this bathroom they're
waiting out the storm
uh there's this horrible noise outside
it almost kind of says the power goes
out and it kind of sounds like maybe a
tornado or something like that is a big
huge crack
and so they so the dad like kind of gets
the door open like a crack like not big
enough to get out of or anything like
that and he kind of shines a cell phone
out there like to see and he's like
basically a tree has fallen into the
house like a massive oak tree has fallen
into the house and is completely
blocking the door so there's no way
they're going to be able to get out
so now they're kind of all trapped in
this bathroom
now
from this point forward
it seems as though there's not really
much of a way for them to get out of
there but as you would they kind of like
their cell phones aren't working
um i think the dad like drops the
daughter's cell phone and she's like
really pissed off about it and then the
other ones are dead it seems kind of
like strange
and even from the beginning you're
thinking well the daughter is kind of
thinking there's something like the
storm that wasn't like a regular storm
there's like not it's there's something
like not right about it
but obviously you know the dad's like
why are you being so stupid i mean the
dad is like really
he's really like a piece of work and
this he's just like a raging like manic
aggro
just [ __ ] the whole entire time and
it's just he never i don't think he says
like a single kind or understanding word
to like anybody in this [ __ ]
like the whole time he's just he's kind
of like he i guess he goes in there and
he has like a thermos like full of booze
and he drinks all of that and then like
the longer they're stuck in there he
starts like drinking the mouthwash and
he's like you know eating the um you
know the alcohol wipes and [ __ ] like
that so it's bad it's bad news and so
he's just getting like more and more
angry at the time because he's
frustrated and he can't get out and he
can't solve the problem and he doesn't
understand like why
something this simple like ended up like
this so he just gets like more and more
crazy like as the movie goes on
so
they kind of figure as you would it's
just a storm they fake a tree fell on
the house they can't get out of the
bathroom
so then they figure well once we'll just
sleep in here and then once the morning
comes you know our neighbors will see
something somebody will like come around
and you know we'll get out of here or
we'll be able to like get phone signal
or something we can call somebody
uh but weirdly that's not really what
happens
the strange thing is that
it doesn't it almost kind of seems like
their phones don't come back on
the sun comes up but they can't they can
sort of see like out of a out of a crack
at the crack in the door
but they don't see anybody outside they
don't hear anything outside and nobody
they have neighbors but like nobody
seems to be coming and checking on them
and so they start to think this is
really really weird
so as i said like the dad is just like
flipping his [ __ ] and he's just getting
more and more frustrated he's just doing
all these stupid things like trying to
get out which aren't working like i said
he's just like ramming into the door and
at one point he like he tries to push
the kid's head through the crack and
it's not gonna fit and it's just like
all this crazy [ __ ] that he's doing
because he's just so frustrated he can't
get out
the mom is kind of trying to
keep a you know keep everybody calm but
being kind of like bullshitting oh
everything's going to be okay and you
know she doesn't want to talk about like
the
fight that her and her husband were
having like right before they went into
the bathroom so the kids are like what
the [ __ ] is going on with you guys why
are you acting like this she's kind of
being a little bit like
cagey dishonest and stuff like that but
in service of like trying to keep
everybody calm and you know especially
in the face of the dad like just
flipping the [ __ ] out
and again as the time goes on you start
to the main character really even though
i've kind of focused more on like the
mom and dad the main character really is
the teenage daughter melissa
as i said even from the beginning when
the storm first started
melissa seemed really
unsettled thinking this isn't like a
regular storm this is something else
and really the only
person's like inner thoughts you get or
flashbacks or memories you get are hers
now as the story goes on and you have
like kind of all these flashbacks that
she's kind of going into
and like i said i don't want to spoil
too much about this because i think this
is just so much better if you go into it
like not knowing what's going to happen
but you get some flashbacks of her and
her like kind of meeting her girlfriend
and
some stuff that they did
that makes melissa think that she's
responsible
for everything that happened like her
parents getting uh but her whole family
getting like trapped in this bathroom
and like the storm outside she kind of
starts to think that she's
responsible for it
and that's kind of as much as i could
say about it because after that like
it's just gonna go in a whole other
direction and and like i said i don't
really want to spoil it
so as i said when i was like watching
this movie
as i said it starts out as kind of like
just like a straight up survival people
trapped in one location and it's like
how are they going to get out maybe
there's some bad [ __ ] going on outside
and you know and there's also uh really
really bad like inter
familial tensions between all of them
like the dad is just getting drunk or
drunker and like losing his [ __ ] and
getting frustrated and like just taking
it out on everybody else so
there's all this like tension inside and
then you know it's just getting
exacerbated because the situation's just
getting worse and worse especially after
the storm goes and nobody comes to help
them and they can't really seem to find
a way out of the situation by themselves
so you have that going on
but then
at one point the movie like i said
there's one point in the movie and if
you've seen the movie you probably know
exactly what i'm talking about there's
one point in the movie where
this thing happens and i was just kind
of like
[ __ ] me i was like holy [ __ ] it like
scared the crap out of me really it
really like made me my mouth drop open
and from then on it kind of goes in a
much weirder
direction like i said where it's um it
can almost be red even though it is
rather it's grounded in reality it's not
like surreal or anything like that
really there are some surreal aspects to
it in the sense of um you seeing a few
things like melissa's dreams or visions
or memories or something some of those
get a little weird and like uh surreal
but also have like symbolic meaning but
other than that it's pretty
rooted in reality and like i said it it
kind of goes in a direction where you
could read it almost like an allegory
but it's still sort of grounded in
reality if that makes any sense so as i
said if you're not a big fan of just
kind of movies entirely set in one looks
like a bunch of characters trapped in
one location squabbling with each other
and then there's something going on
outside that you're not really sure what
it is then maybe you might not dig it
and like i said if you don't like real
ambiguous stuff or stuff that doesn't
give you all the answers in the sense of
ending without like showing you exactly
what was going on then this might piss
you off as well but as i said i really
liked i i mean i thought this was one of
the best low budget films and the use of
just one location and the use of
just leaving things to the you know the
the watchers like imagination i think
this is one of the best examples of that
that i've seen in recent times like i
just thought this was so
great because and it took like all these
twists and turns that i absolutely was
not expecting and
i don't know it was just so so great and
like all the acting like the interaction
between the families i mean that even
when weird [ __ ] wasn't going on like
outside or whatever
outside of the bathroom the tensions
between this family were just like kind
of had me on the edge of my seat i will
say too that there's some pretty if
you're not super into gore this has some
pretty gory uh [ __ ] happening in it and
some pretty bleak [ __ ] happens in this
too and there's like a couple scenes
that were like pretty kind of gross
so
you know it's gross in the sense where i
was just kind of like i'm grossed out by
people like eating gross things and
stuff like that so there was a little
bit of that but if it's pretty gory
though i'm just gonna say and uh it's
pretty violent but
it's so if any of that sounds good
uh definitely watch it like i said
i don't i know this is like it's really
really hard for me to like do a
discussion of it farther than that
because i do kind of feel like this is
really really a movie that you need to
not
know that much about uh going into it or
it's just gonna i don't think it's gonna
ruin it but
i think it'll definitely like lessen
some of its impact uh this is one two
that i definitely want to give a second
watch to one of these days because i
kind of feel like there was a lot of
like i said allegorical stuff going on
in there that you would probably need
like i picked up on a lot of the stuff
but
you'd probably need like a second watch
to pick up on every single thing that
was going on in it but yeah i mean i
can't remember who it was that
recommended this to me but thank you for
recommending it because i really really
dug this one uh quite a bit
uh you can probably rent it on i imagine
you could probably rent it on amazon
prime or something like that i have hulu
so i watched it on there
for free so if you have that it's it's
on there at least as of this recording
and and like i said it's i kind of saw
some reviewers that said that it was
like a slow burn i didn't really find it
slow like i said because
i mean it i don't know it depends on
what you would consider a slow burn
because yeah it's just four people
trapped in a bathroom but like i said
the the tension between the characters
was so high that every single
interaction was just kind of like laced
with
you know you weren't really entirely
sure how the [ __ ] was gonna go like
especially the dad because he was
obviously like going way the [ __ ] off as
rocker so you didn't know if he was
gonna flip out and like start killing
everybody or something because he seemed
like to get more and more unstable so it
kind of seemed like
uh you know even when it was just the
four of them and there wasn't like weird
[ __ ] going on
outside necessarily you were still kind
of like perched on the edge of your seat
thinking like some bad [ __ ] was gonna
explode like just within the family unit
so i think it did a good job of like
balancing
uh you know the inside horror and the
outside horror and they almost kind of
like reflected each other like i said in
a metaphorical sort of way um and i know
i've kind of like talked around
talked around it a lot but
as i said it's kind of better going into
it not really knowing
that much about it so if you've seen it
uh let me know what you thought about it
and let me know if you know
that scene uh that thing that happened
uh if you know what i'm talking about
where my mouth dropped i was when i
gasped because i was i kind of i saw
some other reviews too that said the
same exact thing that that exact moment
made them go like
you know what i mean and i was just like
yeah that's exactly what happened when i
watched it i was like [ __ ] me i just
like it i just did not see that coming
like by any stretch in the imagination
but uh but yeah so let me know if you've
seen it what you thought about it in the
comments or if you want to see it
uh you know let me know if you if it
sounds interesting to you or something
like that or you know let me know if you
hated it maybe you hated it i don't
really know i saw some people uh did a
lot of people seemed like they didn't
like they that they liked the setup and
the concept but a lot of people uh were
kind of disappointed by the ending i can
see that but like i said that's why i'm
giving i was giving that caveat that
if you don't like
endings that are kind of left ambiguous
then maybe this isn't for you but like i
said i didn't mind that i didn't mind it
left in the imagination i don't know i
just thought it was like a really really
great low budget film and i'm curious as
to what everybody else out there thought
about it so let me know in the comments
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye